considera a efe que está definida para
todos los números reales en qué
argumentos x nuestra función
bueno en qué argumento o argumentos x f
x no es diferenciable o no es derivable
es exactamente lo mismo entonces para
ver eso más o menos voy a tratar de
esbozar la gráfica de lo que es la
derivada entonces fijémonos primero en
este segmento en este segmento la
gráfica de la función es una línea
entonces la recta p la la la la recta
tangente perdón tiene la misma pendiente
que ella misma y esencialmente estamos
diciendo que por cada uno de x que nos
movemos a la derecha subimos 2 entonces
tiene una pendiente de 2 así que la
pendiente
digamos digamos de en todos estos puntos
la pendiente es constante y la pendiente
es 2 así que hasta que lleguemos a este
punto aquí viene la gráfica de la
derivada luego resulta que
se convierte en lo bueno deja de ser una
línea tiene un pico y después baja como
en una especie de curva verdad más o
menos como que podemos ver que la
pendiente es aproximadamente 3 digamos
menos 3 es decir por cada uno que nos
movemos en x bajamos 3 más o menos a
grosso modo entonces por aquí la
pendiente va a ser como menos 3 entonces
empezamos por aquí en en menos 3 más o
menos digamos la pendiente de la recta
tangente a que tangente perdón es menos
3 y así va a disminuir o más bien va
creciendo va creciendo hasta que llega
aquí a cero en menos dos aquí va a estar
en cero ok y después empieza a subir
empieza a subir empieza a subir hasta
que más o menos tiene pendiente de uno
por acá
ok más o menos
ok entonces más o menos va subiendo
va subiendo la pendiente hasta qué
llega a uno
que más o menos más o menos
más o menos esta es la idea de cómo se
ve la derivada y después aquí tenemos
una recta que es horizontal y ésta tiene
pendiente cero entonces a partir de este
momento la pendiente se hace cero muy
bien entonces aquí lo que hay que
analizar es que para la gráfica de la
derivada para la gráfica de la derivada
tenemos brincos verdad tenemos estos
brincos y eso va a significar que no
tenemos una función derivable o
diferenciable porque porque
esencialmente estamos calculando la
pendiente de la recta secante y esa red
es esa pendiente y bueno estamos
aproximando a partir de un límite y ese
límite debe coincidir si nos aproximamos
por la izquierda o si nos aproximamos
por la derecha por ejemplo en este punto
en este punto si nos aproximamos por la
izquierda tiende a cero y si nos
aproximamos por la derecha también
tiende a cero entonces aquí sí es
derivable sin embargo en estos puntos
donde hay brincos si nos aproximamos por
la izquierda tiene
valor de 2 pero si nos aproximamos por
la derecha tiene un valor de menos 3 así
que tenemos aquí un brinco en porque los
límites por la izquierda y por la
derecha no son iguales así que para x
igual a menos 8 no es derivable la
función en ese punto y lo mismo pasa
para cuando tenemos x igual a menos 5
así que esta es una forma en la que tú
puedes resolver este tipo de ejercicios